good morning with me are two of my
partners on my left Ben hatch who was
the head of the United States Attorney's
Office in Norfolk before joining McGuire
woods and to my right George Martin my
partner who was among other things the
rector of the University of Virginia Ben
hatch will review the summary
conclusions and then after you hear
again from the president we will come
back and answer your questions yeah
thank you Richard
McGuire woods commenced investigation as
dr. Holman indicated closely on the
heels of the disclosure of the
photograph in early February of this
year our investigation was completely
independent we determined what witnesses
to talk to and what documents to review
we assembled a team that was comprised
of several attorneys and paralegals to
thoroughly review all facts and
documents that team included to my left
Richard :
former Virginia Attorney General former
US Attorney and to my right George
Martin who among many other things has
served as the rector of the University
of Virginia and on the Board of Visitors
of James Madison University and UVA and
several other distinguished attorneys
who are also on the report the time
frame of our inquiry was sat by us and
we have reached the conclusion of our
investigative process we wish to thank
EVMS for its full support and
cooperation with our investigation we
enjoyed unfettered access to EVM asked
personnel and documents throughout our
investigation her GWAR Woods's mandate
was to conduct an independent factual in
bass
Gatien into the EVMS year books
including the 1984 yearbook and to
examine historically the culture of EVMS
with respect to diversity and inclusion
because governor Northam claimed
publicly on February the 2nd that he had
not seen the photograph before we sought
out also to determine if we could who
was in that photograph and how it came
to be on governor Northam personal page
in the 1984 EVMS yearbook and whether
its placement there could have been the
result of an error our report is 36
pages it details our investigative
process the facts that we collected and
our conclusions in the course of our
investigation we interviewed 52
individuals some on multiple occasions
those included the administration
faculty staff current students and
alumni of EVMS we also received the
cooperation of Governor Northam in our
investigation and we interviewed him
twice we interviewed mrs. Northam the
first lady of Virginia members of the
governor's staff and other individuals
with knowledge of the events in around
February first in February second
I'll now proceed to summarize our
conclusions first the culture of EVMS
has always been focused on efforts to
serve the local community
consistent with this EVMS sought to
create a diverse and inclusive
environment almost from its inception
there was no evidence to indicate EVMS
excluded students but as reflected in
some witness interviews it appears there
was often not enough infrastructure our
funding to fully support past diversity
initiatives witnesses report
however that this infrastructure and
funding support significantly improved
in the past five to ten years next
during the past five to ten years EVMS
has taken meaningful steps to improve
and provide consistent support for
diversity and inclusion at the school
these steps are reflected in among other
things improved diversity within the
EVMS student body implementation of
diversity focused initiatives and the
addition of a vice president for
diversity and inclusion as well as
inclusion training nine former and
current students reported to us that
they had experienced what in their minds
were instances of racial and sensitivity
from either other classmates faculty or
during clinical rotations several of
these individuals expressed that those
experiences though were not indicative
of EVMS culture as a whole or were not
unique compared to what they had
experienced elsewhere in their lives
from with respect to the yearbooks from
1976 to 2013 the EVMS yearbooks were
published as an almost entirely
student-run program with little or no
oversight exercised by the EVMS
administration well there was an
administration liaison for the yearbook
in certain years we have identified no
information that indicates that any
faculty or administrators edited or
censored student photographs or the
general contents of the yearbook we did
review the contents of the yearbooks in
detail and as a result of that we have
identified a number of photographs
depicting blackface in the year books
including the photograph that was
disclosed on February 1st 2019 that
depicts an individual and black face and
another individual in KKK robes that
appeared in the 1984 yearbook the
yearbooks repeatedly contains
other content that could be offensive to
women minorities certain ethnic groups
and others these issues are themes
recurred over much of the time period in
which the year books were published
although we know they were less frequent
in the later years of the year books
publication with respect to the
photograph on governor Northam personal
page depicting an individual in
blackface and an individual in KKK robes
we could not conclusively determine the
identity of either individual depicted
in that photograph the governor himself
has made inconsistent public statements
in this regard
no individual that we interviewed has
told us from personal knowledge that the
governor is in that photograph and no
individual with knowledge has come
forward to us to report that the
governor is in the photograph in light
of the governor's statement on February
2nd 2019 that he had not seen the
photograph before we sought to determine
whether there is information that the
photograph was placed on his page in
error or by any other means that were
not at his direction I will note that
our inquiry in this regard was
restricted by the passage of time and by
the dearth of contemporaneous
documentation well we have identified no
information that the photograph was
placed on Governor North impersonal page
in error or by any other means not at
his direction we could not conclusively
determine the origin of that photograph
finally we note that dr. Holman has
announced the creation of the Community
Advisory Board to examine the schools
present culture and make recommendations
in light of the mandate given to the
Community Advisory Board McGuire woods
focused primarily on diversity and
inclusion at EVMs historically because
of the community advisory boards ongoing
work
in their specific mandate McGuire woods
does not make any recommendations within
this report rather if directed by EVMS
we will provide information found in our
investigation to the community advisory
board happy to answer any questions
Oh dr. Holman I'm sorry thank you
I want to just comment and thank
you.thank McGuire woods and their staff
for their work in their extra they're a
very thorough report the report really
is part of our commitment to learn from
the past and become a stronger
institution in the future much of the
good work which was done in the past to
improve the culture of diversity
inclusion at a relatively young
institution rot happened before I
arrived in 2013
since then we've taken even more steps
to improve the culture to provide an
embracing and welcoming environment for
students faculty and staff I'm very
pleased that we've received national
recognition for a lot of the work that
our staff and faculty and students have
done over the past several years we will
continue to build on this infrastructure
to make our school even stronger I'll
close on a medicine medical metaphor
when you have an infection and your
physician tells you that you need to
take the medication for 21 or 14 days
you do not stop when the fever breaks or
the symptoms of 8 because you're likely
to have a recurrent infection and
similarly we are committing ourselves to
long term durable and sustaining
treatment for providing an opportunity
for us to improve the culture of
diversity and inclusion here eliminate
racism and bias wherever you find it and
wherever it is within our reach so I
thank you for being here and we will now
provide opportunity for questions
so the report has extensive reference to
that very important point and I call
your attention to it and and hope that
you would read it closely I mean it was
an obvious question as to why one
statement on the first and another
statement on the second I will answer
that in a second but I want to refer you
to his interview which is attached to
the back of the report and the interview
of his chief of staff which is also
attached as best as he could explain and
what we heard was that while he from the
very first moment on Friday said I do
not believe this is me in the photograph
he qualified that to a certain extent by
saying I don't think that's me I don't
remember that and his staff was faced
with a dilemma and that is laid out in
the report and in the in the interviews
with the staff the dilemma was because
he wasn't saying a hundred percent as
other politicians might have said they
said you can either deny it outright or
you can apologize for it those are your
only two choices governor and he told us
that the most important thing to him is
his honesty and his reputation for
honesty and he decided initially to go
with the apology as opposed to the
outright denial
that you will see in the report was a
surprise to many of his staff you'll see
a reference in the report where one of
his communications people who had been
talking to him expected to be writing a
denial but instead the apology was taken
place so the best we can conclude is
that he he erred on the side of caution
initially and immediately regretted not
having denied and then in his mind tried
to recant or correct the record the next
day yeah I was just gonna saying I'll
close if you if you read this the
statements on these issues they'll do a
better job in reflecting the actual
words than that I'm doing now he started
he remembers the the car the cowboy hat
and the other one but he says he does
not remember the the KKK and the
blackface picture
I learned of this through our chief of
staff and marketing communications
director during the gubernatorial
campaign at that time I had already made
the decision that we were not going to
proceed with any further yearbook
pictures having seen a few in the 2013
yearbook that created a decision for me
where I decided not to continue to
continue those we are a public
institution we receive public funds
we're an institution of higher education
I decided that we are we did not want to
enter any opportunity to have that photo
enter the press or provide a political
process that we're dealing with today
frankly we're apolitical I focused our
work on improving the diversity and
inclusion of our institution and
improving the academic performance of
our of our students and reputation of
EVMS and I did not feel there was an
affirmative duty for me to inform the
governor since it was on his page I I
would make the same decision now if that
were in the same circumstance that's
right we're apolitical and I did not
feel that that was a necessary
disclosure I needed to make my job is to
focus on improving the diversity
inclusion activities and priorities we
have in this in this school improve the
academic performance and the academic
reputation of our institution
I would say that I made the decision
based on the fact that we're a public
institution receiving public funds that
we had discontinued the yearbooks
previously and instead of your
incendiary picture like that had no
bearing for my present job at the time
and the future I was creating for the
institution yeah I don't know I I'll
address that and I think it's not
entirely clear what year it was reported
as being during when it was raised up
prior to dr. Homans tenure to the prior
president of the university it was
reported as being raised up again during
a time when Governor Northam was running
for office he's obviously run for office
on several occasions and then it was
first discovered by alumni affairs
director in relation to a reunion event
where they would typically have your
books out and then that's how she
yes I think it was yes we notified the
governor's office through his counsel
Jeffery bright yesterday afternoon at
about four o'clock of our preliminary
conclusions and then this morning at
about the same time you all were getting
the embargoed
copy we sent them an embargo copy as
well Jeffrey bright so they got the same
thing you got this morning yesterday
they got the summary conclusions yeah
where we are you know as confident as
investigators typically are we're
trained to be skeptical we ask probing
questions and and I think it's fair to
say that we took their statements at
face value and had no reason not to so
in in in in prior years we have no
reason to believe that they were
mistaken so I will answer with regard to
our following leads with regard to who
it might be
in the photograph and we were able to
talk to several who we felt were worthy
of being interviewed based on our
investigative process and one refused to
talk to us
yeah I guess you know you can always say
we could have interviewed one more two
more three more but we interviewed a
very representative sample that we felt
was a valid did the answer your question
yes we did we did pay McGuire Woods
it was a independent review I received
the report yesterday at noon for the
first time they had full access to
whomever they wanted to speak to
wherever their leads led them to and
develop their own independent
conclusions my focus for this
investigation was more focused on the
academic culture at the time so that we
could ensure that we would not repeat
the mistakes of the past administrative
ly as part of EVMS notwithstanding that
my wire woods had full opportunity and
authority to be able to investigate
whatever they wanted to do and they
proceeded with the investigation of the
photograph in more detail and I have to
refer back to them since they conducted
that and I have to assume that it was
done in an objective and thorough
fashion I do not recall that I do not
know I have no no recollection that any
form on anyone from McGuire Woods has
served on our board
but let me make it let me yeah I'd like
to assure you that this was an objective
process we were assured by the school at
every juncture that they wanted to be
transparent and in fairness they didn't
have to do this but they made it clear
to us that we had the ability to speak
with anyone that we felt necessary and
that they would be comfortable with
wherever we ended up in terms of our
conclusions so I assure you that from
our standpoint from a professional
standpoint this was an independent
investigation objective in every respect
and that we had the full support of the
university in terms of their commitment
to being transparent so I mean you've
heard the conclusion we were we were not
able to conclusively determine either
[Music]
person's identity in the picture that's
probably the top the top line I would
say we weighed all the evidence we and
based on that we can't we can't identify
either person but that includes the
governor we weren't able to conclude
that the governor was in the picture so
I think that would be part of the
headline as well
so I think there was not a hierarchy of
importance to the questions that the
there were multiple questions and
conclusions that you heard Mr hatch
answer there was not one that was
preeminent certainly the school was not
as concerned about who was in the photo
then about the situation on campus
through the years and whether there has
been which we've been able to
demonstrate great improvement with
regard to the atmosphere in the in the
culture that we could find yes correct
I don't think we can say it any more
clearly than we said it in the report
there's a conflict right there's a
conflict between what the individual
remembers he says I remember looking at
the yearbook with him but it wasn't his
picture you can interpret that any way
you want and and the governor saying I
don't remember that happening you know
we're yeah we're taking his statement as
face values as we are the other person's
35 years ago he wasn't the governor then
he was just a student not even in the
same class as that person so long Laura
so you know we have to speak through the
report and that's what we've done and
I'm repeating a little bit but but we
weighed all the evidence that we had and
based on that we cannot conclusively
identify either person in the photograph
and that includes Governor northern
no I did not remove those I probably
would have in retrospect place them in a
reserved area that would be out of the
public view but they are public
documents and it was our obligation to
keep those as part of our public library
that we would have I didn't number one I
would they would still be available be
available to the public thank you ladies
and gentlemen we're concluding our press
conference we appreciate you being here
today